the division is for years ahead it's a
long-term vision
uh of connecting to the this ecosystem
uh creating a footprint here and
continuing to grow
and really to benefit uh it's really uh
the idea is really a win-win-win it's
supposed to benefit the people it's
supposed to benefit the israeli
stakeholders and it really is supposed
to benefit of course
the corporation that i work for
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homer ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
let's talk about innovation
meet leo beniakov chief innovation
officer head of partnerships and
ventures mitsubishi corporation
mitsubishi's history is dating back to
the 19th century mc is one of the
largest japanese general trading
companies active in virtually every
industry
lior joined mc's new outpost to help
effectively connect the vast footprint
and resources of a global and
traditional corporation with the
innovative ecosystem that has developed
in israel he is israel's advocate within
the group identifying synergetic
opportunities for collaboration or
investment in verticals such as
agri-food tech industry 4.0 mobility
cleantech and others
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me today how are you
oh i'm doing great thank you very much
for for having me thank you i'm really
excited uh i really enjoy this format
i've watched several of the episodes i
love the
simplicity it's interesting so i hope i
hope i'll do a good job i thank you very
much already starting with the smile i
love it one thing that i that caught me
by big surprise
mitsubishi corporation is not only
mitsubishi cars okay i know i had this
whole episode planned talking about
innovation in cars and here you tell me
that it's actually much bigger and and
the cars is just you know a portion of
the big picture
uh yes that's true so uh and it's
complicated i myself am still learning
it's it's actually a
lot of fun to i'm studying history and
the business
uh
so i work for
uh i'm love i'm the chief innovation
officer
and head of innovative partnerships and
ventures and effectively the deputy gm
of mitsubishi corporation not mitsubishi
mortars in the israel office we're based
in tel aviv and i guess more about
about what i do a little bit later and
it's true um
mitsubishi corp is what you would call a
general trading company one of the
japanese trading companies uh sogo socia
in in in japanese um the larger one
they're not they're not many of them but
they do cover a lot of the japanese
economy so i learned these are
large conglomerates that have been in
existence since
the 19th century when japan was going
through
its first westernization process in the
meiji uh
um era went through evolution after the
the world war and there still exists
today uh so there are other few other
names and mitsubishi corp is one of the
largest ones and indeed as you alluded
mitsubishi motors
is one of our
1400 or 1200 sorry 1200
daughter companies
um
so and it's part of one of the 10
business uh platforms which one of them
is really the automotive sector
and i'm still shocked by the the 1200 i
i've done quite a few episodes i don't
remember many times that i know that i
was in such a big shock in in the middle
of the episode uh
leo you know your your history you know
stemming a lot from agritech as well and
in in innovation and and management
holding key you know vice president
roles amongst so some really interesting
companies being a manager within a car
cargill but then also going to crop x
and accenture and
you know who is leo well you know how do
you end up as being deputy gm and chief
innovation in the teal in the tel aviv
branch of a company that has 1200 dollar
companies
um well that's a good question i need to
i need to ask my wife how that happened
so it's an interesting story i guess uh
yeah you know i i uh i'm married i've
got three three kids grew up in haifa
israel
um
actually to a i guess a multinational uh
family we spoke english at home
and
i guess for about a decade almost a
decade and a half now is
kind of the switch to what i call the
business side so
i started out as a technion graduate
did information system work for a while
but then sort of made the switch when i
went to do my mba at the university of
chicago um
the blue school of business was a very
interesting time uh when i did it the
subprime crisis hit immediately after we
moved
so
you know the joke i sometimes tell my
friends is that i was lehman brothers
last mistake because i interned there
over the summer
in 2008
yeah
okay
so that was uh that was an interesting
time
um
but uh following my mba i joined
the strategy and business development
team of cargill which is a huge
agribusiness the largest private uh
privately owned uh corporation in the
united states
and that unit was sort of it's like an
internal mckinsey for a while and
another part of the time there was with
their internal accelerator
so
i
opened a broad picture for
first of all how these things are done
in terms of the the function so you're
analyzing the innovation you're talking
to startups you're doing internal
innovation doing strategy work and
corporate development work
broadened my mind it was a great school
additional school
you know it
i learned what a real winner was like
when we when i studied in chicago and
then when we moved to minnesota where
headquarters of cargill are uh
my wife and i we learned that it could
be worse
but the but the city itself was was
amazing um
you get a broad picture of many of the
business units
food ingredients ag
trading
um
[Music]
management
uh
you're working with these senior leaders
and then helping them think about the
the special corporate issues that uh
that arise
um it sounds like you had an abundance
of experiences that were really you know
meaningful and impactful that you take
with you until now we're looking at you
know years ago you know what was there
an experience that you know you reflect
back on it and that that you felt took
you from a to b you know on a personal
growth level
um
well yeah i guess several um
if i move forward i think the experience
uh within an actual startup with crop x
so this is a few years ahead of ahead
you know i was talking about cargill at
some point we returned to israel and i
was vp of business development for one
of the
uh
coca-cola israel companies for pregat
and i was touching upon innovation and
startups from i guess from the side of
the large corporations whether they be
global uh by by global standards or
large by israeli standards
and it started to
tickle uh you know you know let's say i
think it makes sense to feel what it's
like from from the inside
and i think that's that's actually very
good advice for anyone doing innovation
or investment at least my opinion was
you have to feel what a startup is from
inside
in parallel i was also thinking about at
the time about agtech and foodtech in a
very bullish manner
i think this is about five years ago i
think i've been proven right with the
various very interesting
valuations we're seeing in the industry
right now and i joined the crop x which
was an amazing precision agriculture
startup as the vp of biz dev
and so to answer your question about the
experience that really developed so of
course
great experiences with cargill then
returning to israel and in crop x it
gave me another perspective
uh this time from the side of the
startup i had to work with these large
corporates and
and
gain their attention because together
with myself maybe 100 other startups are
trying to talk to them and speak to
investors and speak to and work with the
board and work with our management and
the amazing ceo with the company
and learn how to deal with that
intensity and during that time we raised
the series b
round and during that time i i guess
almost single-handedly opened the new
market which was you know dollar wise
maybe not as huge as what the numbers i
would have seen at cargill but very
important for
the development and for funding and
creating value within the startup
and that gave me a very interesting
perspective so corporate and startup
um
and that kind of led into what i'm doing
today
so just before we get into
into today's role because i think that's
it's going to be fascinating on its own
for putting your if we're going back to
where you are at crop x and you're
opening this new market and you're
watching through the the
financing of the series b round
and then you're reflecting back on your
position in this global
company right a coca-cola company and
you're and you're working you're working
in the ecosystem from the corporate and
global level
what do you realize you know in looking
that in retrospective that you are
missing out on because you're mentioning
that you know you think that you know
people who are who are looking to work
in innovation large corporates they can
benefit a lot from working in a startup
what did you benefit you know in
retrospect
well um
when i was
when i joined the startup with the
background of the corporate uh it kind
of gave me a good idea of what
you know what the corporates were
thinking and what their
agenda is
uh whether it's a personal agenda of the
individuals you're working with or the
agenda of their division
you know let's not be naive it's it's
not always the uh the same agenda
sometimes you know they're they're in
their interests and and people and
opinions and a little bit of politics
and you learn and you know and for you
know sometimes young people within the
startup who haven't had the the
experience with maybe a global corporate
that has worked with a startup from the
other side
they don't really understand what's
going on why is it taking so long and
why are they asking these questions
again and again repetitive are they uh
are they disrespecting us are they
trying to just you know push us push us
off and you have to
um under be resilient in that situation
um
[Music]
not too pushy but yet also you have to
always have you know your finger on the
pulse they say in hebrew
to get back and to follow up and to
uh you know this is true for all
startups be ready to hear or know and
maybe and and and work around
um but you really understand what's
going on and when i began working as
part of cropx
bringing in an investor who was who
happened to be a company similar to
mitsubishi one of our competitors
another japanese
sogo social general trading company
you know that was that was a difficult
experience it was almost uh
you know sometimes i i felt like oh my
god what's going on what are they
again they're asking this they asked
these questions two two weeks ago and
two months ago what's going on
uh in retrospect today when i'm part of
a japanese company
in a large corporate
i i knew what was i knew what was going
on and by by the way there was a happy
happy ending there uh they asked many
questions it was very difficult and
sometimes tedious but they invested
which was a very important strategic
investment so
uh not saying that that's always the
case when you speak to a company such as
ours and pitching your uh your startup
but uh
it will happen
incredible i hope that answers the
question 100 percent fast forward to
today december of 2021 mitsubishi
corporations
innovation working with the ecosystem
here
what is it all about for you
perfect so
uh
in some ways it feels like i'm opening a
small startup uh within a large
corporate here in israel together with
my amazing gm who is a japanese national
who who lives now in israel
um
we are really
the advocates for the israeli ecosystem
within this very broad world let's call
it a mitsubishi corp
uh and and the and the
it's its reach across
not only japan and not only asia but but
globally
what we're trying to do is identify at
this point we are what you would call a
liaison office or
we're trying to identify opportunities
whether it would be with funds but
mostly with startups and maybe other
stakeholders in several verticals um
whether it's avery foodtech mobility
industry 4.0 cleantech areas that could
be synergetic for our group the group
covers
virtually every type of industry
and the idea is to be able to connect
them to the right business unit or to
the right daughter company
and facilitate
beyond just
matchmaking there try to facilitate
something that will turn into
collaboration and collaboration can be
anything a pilot something commercial
uh hopefully also investment lead to
investment
and you know keeping in mind our
internal processes
things take time but the division is for
years ahead it's a long-term vision
of connecting to this ecosystem
creating a footprint here and continuing
to grow
and really to benefit uh it's really uh
the idea is really a win-win-win it's
supposed to benefit the people it's
supposed to benefit the israeli
stakeholders and it really is supposed
to benefit of course
the corporation that i work for
[Music]
now when you're looking at the israeli
ecosystem and
you know there's a lot of innovation
going on a lot of startups
how are these relationships forming
right now sort of what is the process
that you go through in forming these
relationships with the israeli ecosystem
you know both on the inbound and the
outbound level
so
right now we're a very small operation
and uh
little did i know but when i joined it
was only a few weeks before covet
started so things uh
have changed a little bit in terms of
speed and and your ability to work but
the strategy is really uh
to create a funnel so
my day to day is really speaking the way
we're speaking now with as many uh
companies as i can
analyze which ones myself and my and the
gm analyze which ones might be relevant
uh together uh analyze which ones might
be first of all interesting in general
and then interesting force whichever
business within within our group and
then try to facilitate those by making
the right introductions and connections
and providing the right follow-up and
being our the
the person on the ground for
um other decision makers within within
the group
but you're talking about a group that
has 1200
dollar companies
that's right we're not gonna we're not
going to speak with all 1200 uh the
group is organized into kind of 12
divisions by industry so i'm not going
to remember remember them all so of
course there's the auto and mobility
because you mentioned that but there is
mining chemicals energy
infrastructure
agri-food of course which is uh kind of
my baby and
and a few others
um
and within the verticals we're looking
at the strategy is in order to
get some sort of a multiplier effect is
also to work with stakeholders that can
have a aggregate effect so an example
would be this is public uh
a relationship we've created with the
the agri-food uh
investment arm or accelerator called
trend lines um you may have heard of
them very highly reputable so together
with them i can cover that vertical even
though we're only a small number of
people and we're looking to do similar
things uh maybe with other outfits that
cover other verticals uh in i4 mobility
etc and of course directly to speak with
with startups
and uh when we find the ones that
you know meet the meet the character the
criteria of one interesting two
it someone caught the
bait is not the word but someone wants
to champion it internally then we'll
push forward as much as we can
but our vision going forward is to
evolve
uh and cut these processes short
and to
you know some of our some of the other
japanese companies have evolved into a
cvc a corporate vc
um we want to evolve that way as well
whether the first step will be some sort
of a hybrid model which can be very
interesting and maybe
further on in the future an actual cvc
what is your role as you see it in the
israeli ecosystem today you know things
are evolving quickly there's you know
israel is a powerhouse in in every way
possible and and people like you as far
as i see their their catalysts in
different ways shapes and forms what is
your role in the israeli ecosystem today
um
i i really i really agree with the way
you defined it uh catalyst is a great
way to put it now when i describe to my
friends what my my role is i say that
it's a hybrid of vc business development
uh scouting and a little bit of
the israel export institute you know
in hebrew
because we're here to represent and
really work for these for the local
stakeholders it's literally our job to
help them
for free to try and get into this
very large traditional uh complicated
organization
which has a long very long term view
so maybe it's a disadvantage this
complexity but
there are huge advantages
for any stakeholder trying to work with
us
just by virtue of connecting with the
resources and the name and the
connections
that such an organization can have um
just just you know imagine a startup
working to
raise funds in one of the one of the
rounds and he can and the startup can
publish hey we're doing a pilot with
mitsubishi corp
wow that's uh that's a big thing
it might not be the hugh the biggest
headline in seatek but it's a very big
thing and these are some things we're
looking for well usually investment
yeah
sometimes you know the more strategic
things in and around don't don't don't
often make it to the headlines they're
the you know the deeper things that
require a little bit more introspection
to really dig deep into and so i can
definitely understand that um and and i
i just want to say leo that i think it's
it's so cool
you know to be in a position where
you're when you're at there's
some jealousy in my in my tone of voice
here because you really you know you're
sitting in this intersection of on one
hand this phenomenal phenomenal you know
in innovation hub this you know the
miracle of the state of israel
at the same time you're representing you
know such an incredible company
mitsubishi corporation with you know
really in touching in all aspects of our
lives dealing with some of the most cool
products in the world and you get to a
you know bridge the gap between the two
and play a really pivotal role and i and
i really so so first of all thank you
for for your
part of of this ecosystem and really
also thank you for these 20 minutes i
really really enjoyed them and i learned
a lot and i get a lot of inspiration for
myself so really thank you
thank you very much it was really fun
and i really appreciate it look forward
to seeing it thank you very very much
thank you so much
[Music]
you